やっと撮影環境が整ってきたぞ
こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
はじめアミューズメントパーク東京支部もやっと撮影場所っぽくなってきました
まあ机があれば多分撮影はできると思うので
これからはこういう感じで東京でも撮影していければいいなと思っております
というわけで今日はちょっとしばらく東京にいて
やりたいこと沢山あるんですけども
色々と静岡に置いてきちゃってて
東京にしばらくいるんでちょっとやることもないんで
とある物を皆で見ていきたいと思います
皆さん”Amazon”で買い物はしますでしょうか？
インターネットよく使う人なら
インターネットよく使う人だったら多分”Amazon”でよく買い物すると思うんですけども
さーて皆さん
皆さんYouTuberという生き物は”Amazon"でどんな物を買うかご存知でしょうか
Amazon超ヘビーユーザーです
家には常にAmazonの箱が山積みになっていて
玄関は基本的にAmazonの段ボールでめちゃくちゃになってて
これだけの要素があるともう基本的にAmazonでしか買い物しなくなって
というわけで今回は
まあちょっと今日は落ち着いた動画にしましょう
のんびり、軽い気持ちで見てくだせー
果たしてオイラのAmazonの購入履歴は果たしてどんな物を買っているのかという
今日は皆さんに見せていこうと思います
変なの買ってたらやだな
はいというわけでこんな...やべ本名だ！
あ、隠せばいいのか
まあ大体お察しがつくでしょう
チェックした商品の関連商品は全部”遊戯王カード”でございます
はいというわけで僕の今までやってきた購入履歴を見ていきましょう
2012年とかのもある
2012年何買ったか調べてみよう
うわ懐かしいな～買ったなこれ
すっごい昔なんですけど
カラーバターっていう髪の毛を、色を付けるやつを昔買っていました
2012年の年末か
年末に買ってるんだね
"slackline"
なんかこう紐を張って遊ぶスポーツがあるんですけど
この頃に"MacbBook"
2012年に”MacBook Air"を買ってますな
2012年はあんま買ってないんだね
待って、俺2013年とか何買ったんだろう
2013年の1月には
おおフィルムやっぱちょっとYouTuberぽいっすねここら辺から
2013年からYouTuberっぽい
なんかレンズにかけるカバーとか
液晶フィルムとか買ってましたね
あ、ジャングルブーツっていうメリタリー系のブーツを買ってました
Levi'sの靴
cheero Plus
充電したかったんでしょうね
ホモォのぬいぐるみリュック白タイプを買ってます
画像がありませんね
レシラムを吸収したキュレムのぬいぐるみ買ってます何を考えてたのでしょうか（ポケモン）
ワンタッチレンズキャップ
あ、そうだ懐かしいな
ここら辺ノコギリヤシとかヘアトニックとかなんなんだろう
なんか人生のこの先禿げるのかなと思った時期がありまして
禿げるのいやだなーと思って禿げないような物をここら辺で買ってました
懐かしいなｗ一回も使わなかったやｗｗ
一眼レフのケース
三脚
ハンドルグリップ
こうやって持ってカメラを（で）撮るやつですね
すっげー俺やる気まんまんじゃん
Mac用のマイクロソフト
Excel（エクセル）とかパワーポイントを使おうと思ってここでMacのそれを買いました
めっちゃレンズキャップ買うじゃん
え、買いすぎでしょこれもう何回買ってるの？
まあよく無くしたんだと思います
あ、SDカードとか買ってますね
三脚
うおーすげーな
2013年はなんか・・・
イカれてたのかな
2014年いってみましょう
はいというわけで2014年でございます
うわ、ここはなんだろう
ゲーム実況をしたい気持ちになったんだと思います
コンデンサーマイクとか
風の
webカメラとかゲームパッド...あっ
メガゴキブリも買ってますな
この頃からドッキリに対する好奇心とかが湧いてたみたいですね
もう２年前か
歳を取ったな俺も
まだミリタリーブーツに憧れがれがありました
ゴリラの着ぐるみ６点セット
照明を買いましたね
また三脚買ってる
HDMIケーブル
wii用映像変換アダプタ
ライト　TOEILIGHTって何買ってんだ俺
おもしろアイマスク　萌え~
あ～懐かしい
なんか僕は多分ね２年前ちょうどねサルエルパンツのブームが僕の中で来てて
すごいサルエルパンツを買いまくってました
ドボドボしてる服にちょっと魅力を感じ一時期ハマりました
コカ・コーラゼロ1.5Lを８本８本８本
え、俺何してるのこれ
は？は？あ、そうだ
”コーラ風呂”したときだ
あ、そうだそうだそうだｗ
コーラ風呂はAmazonで注文しました
若かったわかった馬鹿丸出しだったよまじで
日本クラフト　メントス１２個入り
ここら辺完全にイカれてるなぁ
野々村Tシャツ　耳をすませばバージョン黒
アクアボールも買ったしマネキンも買いましたねここで
ふわっとかおる女子高生の髪の匂い
蛇を買いまくった後に
今も使ってるコタツ
もう２年間も使ってるんだね
ハンマーで叩いても壊れないコタツも果て２周年でございます
地中海窓辺ステッカー
壁に貼ってると海に行ってる気持ちになれる壁紙
MacBookProをここら辺で買っちゃったのかな？
うわ、またレンズキャップ買ってんじゃん
鼻水が出てくる　ノーズディスペンサー
白雪姫のMacBookステッカー
人をダメにするソファ
ここから俺はダメになりました
ここら辺で多分容量の限界を感じたのでポータブルハードディスク買って
百味ビーンズ
ユニバーサル自分で行けよ
あぁ＾～ここら辺からですわ
ちょうど２年前から僕は”遊戯王”にドハマりしちゃって
ここから多分遊戯王が多くなると思います
めっちゃ買うやん
ミリタリージャケットにハマった時期もありましたね
これからEOS70Dに変えてそれ系の物を買ったりしてますね
後はひたすら遊戯王カードです
あーサルエルパンツ
デェエルディスク
ホウ砂
ことばの習得ー母語習得と第二言語習得
え？
デルガード２年前から使ってるんだね
洗濯ノリ
アスナ（？）のスリーブを買っております
文章読本
小説神髄
シュールストレミングもAmazonで買ったんだね
ここでまたメリタリーブーツ...メリタリーブーツ買いすぎでしょ
服買いに行くの面倒臭かったので全部Amazonで買ってました安いやつ
チュッパチャップスのツリー丸ごと買いました
やっぱ基本遊戯王だな
爆竹買ってる
遊戯王カードしか買ってねぇなってところがありましたね
次
2015年でございます
ここは単焦点レンズを買ってテンションが上がっておりました
ゲームレコーダー買い始めたの見せかけて結局は遊戯王
あ、プレオだ
プレオ壊れてて一回返品というかやり取りしてたんですよね
鼻毛カッターを買ってますね
鼻毛が気になってたんでしょうね
スーパーボール３００個セット買って
なぜか人をダメにするソファをもう一回買ってる
(｡◕ˇдˇ​◕｡)/カオナシのコスプレ衣装とか
あ、WiiU買ってるねここで
服のシワが気になってたのでここでアイロンを買いましたね
気持ちだけはもうPewDiePieでした（世界一登録者の多いスウェーデン人のYouTuber）
はいというわけで僕が今までAmazonで買ってきた物でした
では皆さんいよいよ８月に入るので良い夏を
じゃあな
日本語字幕作成者：今日の一言